the hardest thing was hysteric regs
Estero yeah who's mark he is acting like
such a cool nice awesome sweet dude who
thought this was just a [ __ ] thing
that was gonna go away do you know what
I mean like yeah it was like whatever it
is my first acting how many times you do
something early on in Hollywood we were
like just what I did I did the
underground comedy movie that for a
decade they did advertisements on that
late at night on Comedy Central dude I
remember that and I was in those
advertisement I had to get a lawyer I
had got a lawyer to get out of to get
out of it oh my because he paid me 50
bucks back in the day in the 1997 when I
did it and then it's not 2006 and it's
still like playing on Comedy Central how
much money did he put in a marketing to
have that run because he Vince offered
to is the guy that he says ShamWow guy
oh right so he made a millions of
dollars he's that if he's like an
infomercial king or whatever is he alive
he's still alive yes die somebody died
right didn't one of them dad yeah but
then Vince offered did Vince is the guy
that like bit of hookers face yes but
Vince offer remit he we made the movie
I've done that so many times he remade
the [ __ ] movie and he put Adrien
Brody in it we did it he did it I think
Whitney Cummings days he paid them a lot
of money okay I was just gonna say it's
either money or connections he didn't
know anybody that knew them this was
just him throwing money and know it then
yeah but and they won't even read me
remade it yes but then he's like I'm
gonna use your scene from the first
movie and that's when my lawyer goes if
we're gonna sue if you do that so then
he got a different Asian guy to do it oh
my God thank God
yeah is it available on DVD can I buy it
yeah you can buy yeah but I'm not in the
second one oh you're not I'm in the
first look I need that why I just need
it for be in it
yeah to the accent I don't even remember
what I want either day I think somebody
dubbed my lies yeah you knew who else is
in it Michael Clarke Duncan
for anything before green mouth yeah
way before it was like we had nobody
then what was the budget on movie I
don't know I was living in San Diego I'm
in an open mic in La Jolla he fans
offers there right yeah you can see it
buddy hey buddy um hey man I'm a
director I mean I do infomercials but I
had a lot of money
I got cool you guys anybody um you're
very funny I have the Asian guy for my
movie and in my head since I live in San
Diego yeah I have a waiting job I just
started doing stand-up Hollywood this is
it I'm in so I drove up there he paid me
50 bucks I was there for days I remember
50 bucks yeah that's a that was it
you're in how is it yeah and then cash
to DV cash what was cash we go I had
when I drove back the windows down
ya know I I didn't get a spot at open
mic and I yelled at the guy I'm in a
movie movie you know just wait just wait
you'll know what movie to run for 10
years then I'll later be replaced by
another agent
have you ever had one of those been in
not him well I was in a I was in like a
I did so many like sketches or student
film II type of things I did want I did
this one that I can't get the credits
scrubbed off an IDI DMB yeah I BMD am I
get it off at IBM what is it gonna look
at what is it you can it's on there it's
called crafty it was about the craft
service industry watch you'll see I'm
the Pope I think I'm on the it was this
guy it was a friend of a friend that I
knew at the time he's like I'm making
this thing and I thought yeah okay I'll
do this like little things like it took
a little it was like a web series type
of thing and I thought nothing of it I
was like yeah maybe I'll just do it and
to this day I'm like can I please email
president
is that from her like a reputable
company that did it like no would you
see a young friend of a friend who's a
really good dude and he's like since
then obviously done his own thing but
like it was just we all kind of work no
no we're doing kind of hurt yeah well
he's a nice guy and I love it but 2009
crap oh my god weird it looks where are
you you're not on there right dude I'm
the one lifting my arm up that's about
you right there yeah let me see crafty
yeah you can't even tell no I know you
shouldn't even set it on this podcast
available for their you so light married
is firm well they'll never find it
that's the thing there's no where to
find it oh there isn't you can't get it
yeah that was the other thing I was like
I said I sent an email to to the
Internet Movie Database and I was like
this isn't a thing anymore
but because he register registered it
with the Union you know and register it
with as a sag ultra-low budget whatever
it stays you can't get anything on your
IMDB off nothing if you did it it's
there it's up where you found it we're
trailer right yeah the Train can see the
trailer guys on IMDB it's funny it was
just the thing I did I said to everyone
listening right now that